[Música]
ella me encantaba andar aquí en este de
santo domingo
[Aplausos]
hablando de florecitas pornográfico
d
mi nombre fernández yo soy fotógrafo de
conservación
un fotógrafo de conservación es
básicamente un fotógrafo de naturaleza
pero conociendo la conservación es
básicamente un fotógrafo naturaleza que
hace imágenes que el propósito propósito
y obviamente de conservar
yo trabajo en diversos proyectos
la publicación de un recorrido
fotográfico
de la biodiversidad de una isla
título un poquito largo pero
y ese mismo año porque yo soy importante
obsesivo-compulsivo y me gusta cargarme
de trabajo saque también una aplicación
sobre la tierra de mañana
para el libro de la horquilla del
espanyol
fotografía ciento y pico de especies de
orquídeas
y
está ella para que usted lo sepa
que más especies
y para ubicar la mezquita y tuve que
hacer contacto con este señor el doctor
luís mario benedetti
si ya estás naturalistas también eran
miembros la academia de ciencia de
república dominicana era un fanático de
las orquídeas y ayuda a la sociedad
adquiriente república dominicana y él
[Música]
yo quiero que tuve otro grupo de plantas
trabajando
no
o sea todos
las flores son súper interesantes
consiguen de la localidad a la horquilla
que necesito
el caso es el sector marion también
es un dibujo especial ver que la flora
tenía en forma muy interesante ya mucha
relación y en el 2011 él sacó una guía
con sus propias frustraciones y entonces
la orquídea o sea a llamar muchísimo la
atención pero no lograba ver un edificio
entonces salía el campo busqué
información tuve que aprender que era un
arito lock ya y básicamente descubrí que
son enredaderas de tronco maderos o con
flores eróticas y entonces eso fue lo
que me llamó la atención o sea no hay
una razón más grande que yo
y están en peligro crítico no eran
formas muy interesantes
y descubrí también que habían el 60 por
ciento de toda la diversidad de arista
lo que está concentrada en tres lugares
brasil que es un continente méxico otro
continente y en la isla de la española
una islita
y eso me pareció súper interesante
también aprendí que había nueve especies
nativas para que usted entiendan lo que
es una especie nativa es una especie que
tenemos aquí quizá en cuba' quizá en
centroamérica quizá en sur américa que
compartimos con otros lugares pero las
que son verdaderamente importantes son
las endémicas que solamente existen
dentro de nuestro país o de nuestra isla
este es un ejemplo grandiflora de una
especie nativa que tenemos aquí las
flores son enormes son suramericanas en
una especia suramericana no estoy
exagerando
lo interesante de esta flor es
suramericanas que huelen a rayos ea
vuelven a heces fecales a orina atraen
unas moscas que son las que polinizan la
flor que básicamente son flores que se
atraen por ejemplo cuando pasa un
caballo y deja caer un regalito y se
llena de moscas esas son las moscas que
van a polinizar la flor y obviamente
tienen que imitar el olor de
de las heces fecales en las formas
eróticas
estas son algunas de las endémicas haití
en sis
pero but a los polis las flores por
ejemplo solamente están vivas por tres
días el día uno se ve así se ve la flor
se ve o se tiene esa parte de arriba que
parece una lengua se llama el limbo y
entonces el limbo se va retorciendo
doblando el día 2 y ya el tercer día
empieza la flor a marchitar y caer
producen frutas los frutos son esas
bolas verdes que ustedes ven y esos
frutos dentro de poco tiempo se secan
abren y sueltan una semilla que tienen
como un ala y eso es un diseño especial
que tienen para dejar salir para dejarse
llevar por el viento entonces donde
encontramos esto lo que a bueno resulta
que
en el peor de los sitio básicamente o
sea tú va manejando por una carretera y
tú con un alambrado de púas y ahí están
las aristas esto sea esto se llama esto
encierra de neiva pero es una localidad
tipo de una especie nueva imagínense
cuando yo ustedes se imaginan de que
donde hay una especie nueva de arista
lópez bueno 11 sistema generando un
bosque súper sano pero miren lo que hace
la realidad es otra
alambre de púa el lado de carretera en
haití con todo cortado deforestado
pero tienen toda una cantidad de trucos
para atraer a esas poquitas de esas
pequeñas moscas como son esas ventanas
traslúcidas entonces yo usando mi cámara
para tratar de con los flashes imitar
quizás osea cuando ustedes ven una flor
y tú le tira un flash de frente se ve la
flor completamente iluminada como para
nuestros fines o sea como la vemos
nosotros pero quizás los insectos ven
las cosas de otra forma y yo quise
mostrar usando un truco de flash como
arito lo que tienen estas ventanas
translúcidas que engañan a la mosquita
la mosquita viene volando y ve esa
claridad y piensa que puede volar a
través de eso entonces lo que hace es
que choca cae por el tubito y entonces
en el tubito hay unos pelos que están
todo en una dirección y la mosca se
arrastra básicamente en una dirección
porque no puede salir hacia atrás y cae
en la parte donde está el polen y
entonces la mitología son media
desgraciada porque dejan al insecto
atrapado 24 horas ahí dentro entonces
los pelitos empiezan a marchitar como
ustedes vieron en la foto anterior
y entonces el insecto entonces es libre
de salir pero ya ha cargado de polen o
sea ya tienen que asegurarse
reteniendo el insecto 24 horas
eso es una hormiga y las hormigas no
están politizando lazarito loca pero las
visitan hay muchísimas cosas que no
sabemos todavía
yo sé que ahora mismo yo parezco
botánico pero no lo soy y todo esto es
un proceso de cubrimiento a través de la
fotografía y de usar la cámara como una
herramienta también para
para contribuir con el conocimiento de
la historia natural de estas plantas
aparte de polinizadores o sea de
mosquitas que entra y se cargan de polen
y visitan una flor y van polinizando una
flor y otra las arista locas tienen otra
particular y particularidad las hojas
alimentan un grupo de mariposas las
orugas de un grupo de mariposa
especialmente las del género ba tus va a
tu pool y dame una mariposa que tiene
una distribución muy amplia en el caribe
en cuba en jamaica puerto rico son
bastante comunes pero entonces lo que
hace la mariposa que viene y coloca el
huevito arriba de la hoja o sea
imagínense la inteligencia que tiene un
animal de esto que dentro de un monte
sabe entre todas las hojas que ve cuál
es la litología va a esa planta las
orugas solamente comen arito logias y
pasan por 50 días
y entonces en cuba tenemos otras
especies muy vistosas paredes con la que
'nos
que es súper bonita la oruga es súper
interesante también
y es solamente de cuba para yo entender
todo este grupo de plantas yo tuve que
básicamente empezar a estudiar y como
ustedes pueden ver ese es una
descripción de una listo lógica en un
lenguaje que que nadie entiende
miren esas tres palabras de que ella
esos primero está en inglés pero en un
idioma inglés botánicos entonces yo tuve
que comprarme un glosario de términos
botánico ponerlo en mi casa y cada vez
que buscaba la referencia o la
descripción de una planta que yo todavía
no sé qué es eso o sea yo tendría que
consultar el glosario para saber qué es
este es otro obstáculo que me ha
encontrado en este proceso de cubrir
arito lo que has anterior por favor
hay unos bancos de información por
ejemplo si yo quiero buscar la
descripción original de una planta de
1895 hay unos bancos de información
online donde yo puedo acceder esa
información pero como yo no estoy
afiliado una institución ya tengo un
proyecto personal me sale ese letrero
pues hay una apertura permission to
access de aires no sé a qué todavía se
me ha hecho sumamente difícil
y poder encontrar información de las
plantas
entonces fui al herbario del jardín
botánico y empecé a consultar las fichas
del barrio pero como ustedes pueden ver
tú lo que tiene una planta marrón una
flor marrón y de eso tú no puedes sacar
ninguna información para tu sabes de qué
color o qué es tan atractivo en la
planta entonces todo eso motivó que yo
salía en el campo con mi cámara a tratar
de fotografiar todo lo que todas las
aristas locas que podía también en el
proceso empecé a tomar mediciones
nuevamente no soy yo yo saqué malísima
nota en biología pero yo creo que mi
profesor dario orgulloso ahora mismo de
ese trabajo tengo que dibujar la
plantilla la florecita poner el nombre
de tomar una serie de medidas y
anotaciones y empecé a colectar tejido
tejido de plantas básicamente una
muestra de hojas algunas flores
y
empecé a colectar especímenes prensado
para el bario y empecé a compartir esos
especímenes a donarlos al jardín
botánico porque ya yo había revisado
compulsiva obsesivamente su colección y
sabía cuáles especies le faltaban
también o sea como ustedes ven
tuve colectar flores en alcohol porque
eventualmente si eran especies nuevas
quién iba a ilustrar la especie nueva
tenía que tener la flora en alcohol para
poder hacer la ilustración de las flores
también tuve que exponerme a muchísimas
dificultades por ejemplo eso es un bote
un speed
que tuve que entre tierra firme y
la isla con haití déjeme decirles yo
puse a con tiburones con ballena con yo
me he puesto cualquier tipo peligro pero
para mí yo pensaba que me iba a morir
ese día
fueron 40 minutos de agarrarme de un
clavo así de lado dando brincos en el
peor mar del mundo y imagínense esa
gente tienen que y salir de la
isla a diario básicamente
es la cara de asustado de los compañeros
miedo del bote que también
también
he viajado en mulos ese es un compañero
mío botánico que sí sabe lo que está
haciendo entonces yo soliciten su ayuda
para yo poder conectar alguna esta cosa
entonces que hemos logrado en todo este
tiempo o sea con toda esta fotografía de
pronto yo empecé a ver que las fotos que
yo tenía y las flores que yo tenía no
estaban en la guía del doctor mario
entonces y tampoco había ni se parecían
tampoco alguna de las especies
centroamérica ni de las otras islas del
caribe ni y resulta que después de
consultar con la universidad de harvard
donde yo tenía unos amigos que habían
trabajado en el libro de hispaniola
conmigo resulta y viene al caso que
parece ser que todas estas plantas son
nuevas
eta eta
esta tiene la singularidad y es una cosa
muy extraña y estamos tratando de
determinar qué está pasando pero si
ustedes ven esas tres flores pensarían
que son tres especies diferentes bueno
están una al lado de otra en un lugar
tienen unas variaciones de patrones
increíbles en este sitio y para mí son
una sola especie lo que pasa que tienen
una estrategia de cambiar el patrón para
engañar al polinizador otra vez un truco
más y eso lo vamos a saber porque tuve
que colectar tejido de una planta al
lado de la otra y ahora se va a hacer
toda la secuencia de adn en la
universidad de harvard próximo
próximo
esas dos la anterior y estas se parecen
un poquito pero crecen en dos lugares de
la isla completamente diferente para mí
son dos especies diferentes pero estas
son ese es un caso donde tienen un
parecido y hay que esperar por ejemplo
que los resultados en la secuencia de
adn lleguen
esta que está aquí sabemos que es una
especie nueva
esperar los resultados del adn porque la
flor es muy diferente a todos los otros
y de hecho se está haciendo una
publicación próxima
donde también se estaba escribiendo ella
y la amarilla que vieron se van a
describir tres especies nuevas ya esas
son las ilustraciones que se están
haciendo a partir de hecho de la
fotografía que estoy haciendo y de las
flores conectadas en alcohol próximo
esos son especímenes ya de ellas que se
están depositando también en la
universidad de harvard porque hay que
acompañarlo de un espécimen físico
y las arito logias tienen amenaza igual
que todo en este país que tiene que ver
con la naturaleza el carbón es una de
ellas
esto es en haití básicamente ese señor
tiene que ganarse la vida y no tiene
otra forma ni otra alternativa y corta
el monte en el proceso de cortar todas
las plantas y los árboles que están ahí
y hacer carbón ese es una carretera
donde había una localidad tipo también
donde había una especie nueva y cuando
yo volví
a conseguir más información y más data
método poco aunque el alcalde decidió
chatear y arreglar la cartera y me cortó
todas mis matica entonces logré
encontrar unas que estaban un poquito
más adentro del bosque pero también eso
es una amenaza imagínense él no sabe que
está cortando una especie nueva entonces
este es el mapa de áreas protegidas de
la española esta república dominicana
pero en haití tenemos un par de áreas
protegidas también
si ustedes se fijan
todo es tan todo lo público tan fuera de
área protegida o sea que ahora mismo
mucha de esta planta y muchas de estas
especies nuevas no tienen ningún tipo de
protección no es como que si estuvieran
en un área protegida estarían protegidas
de todas formas pero porque sabemos que
las cosas no funcionan así en otro país
pero por lo menos en papel estarían en
un área donde si uno ve algún tipo de
amenaza uno pudiera interceder pero
ahora mismo están todas fueras excepto
una especie que es arista lo que a
montana cuando yo llegué al lugar donde
encontrar listo lo que montana que era
la última especie descrita del espanyol
la que me faltaba por encontrar veo una
mariposa endémica que se llamaba tu
sepides yo nunca en 25 ó 30 años andando
los montes había visto esa mariposa
solamente la había visto el libro y ahí
estaban y botas
entonces asumí inmediatamente que la
planta hospedera era arito loca montana
y eso nunca se había descrito no
solamente no se había descrito la planta
hospedera no se habían descrito los
huevos las cinco etapas de la oruga y en
contra el 14 esos 14 huevos
y cuando se acababa la comida y nama
como en esa hoja tenía que montarme un
carro vaya nuevo a buscar más hojas está
15 minutos recogiendo se vuelve manejar
tres horas para atrás para acá y
entonces
ahí la vemos recién mudada mira como tan
bien alimentada está en esa oruga
parecen dos poquito
proceso de transformación de orugas para
nada de esto todo esto es una primicia
ni siquiera se ha publicado tuve que
pasar por tres orugas para conseguir eso
lo innova me apretó una luz ósea
[Música]
ahí sale la crisálida húmeda va
despojándose de la piel
y ahí termina ella porque se descolgó y
falló la poca a veces eso pasa las
condiciones climatológicas de santo
domingo no son igual que en valle nuevo
esos animalitos son muy niño
y entonces como ustedes pueden ver este
es el sitio
esa planta solamente se encontraba en
esa cañada yo peine todo esa loma y nada
más habían plantas hospederas y la
mariposa solamente está en esa cañada
imagínense el estado de vulnerabilidad
en el que se encuentra tanto la planta
como la mariposa y entonces buscando
información sobre la mariposa me topo
con esto
un espécimen de la mariposa conectado
para museo con su alfileritos 690 euros
14 calculen eso por 14 huevos yo pensaba
que me iba a ser millonario en mi caso
pero eso es un problema porque si yo
público la localidad de dónde está esa
cañada imagínense todos esos colectores
van agarrar con colador y había
colectado en mariposa y se pone la
patineta entonces no sé qué voy a hacer
todavía con la información y como la voy
a publicar pero eso representa una
situación y un problema
cuál es el valor de la planta de qué
sirve todo esto si el audio está
gustando muchísimo buscando especies
nuevas y es un tripe o
me encanta está en el monte y yo la paso
bien y gracias yo tengo un par de
empresa apoyando por lo menos cubriendo
los gastos de ese proceso aunque sea un
proyecto personal pero
básicamente la planta tienen
un valor directo valor indirecto y valor
intrínseco un valor directo puede ser
que producen medicinas como el caso de
tps que está aquí en república
dominicana producen alimentos de hecho
se usan o sea podemos ver el uso de esa
planta directamente y el valor indirecto
se llama en servicios ecosistémicos se
absorben co2 producen oxígeno y regulan
el clima eso no es tan tangible para la
mayoría de la gente y la gente
especialmente los republicanos eeuu
y el valor intrínseco ya que estas
plantas se merecen un lugar
independientemente de nosotros
o sea
son parte del patrimonio natural de
nuestro país de nuestra isla nosotros
somos una isla más rica porque
precisamente tenemos una diversidad muy
amplia de estas plantas pero
en este caso que tenemos una especie
cuyos extractos de la raíz produjeron
una medicina que ayuda a encoger el
tumor de sarcoma y ayuda a prolongar la
vida de un en este caso el paciente era
una rata
que tenía leucemia entonces cada vez más
estamos volcándonos a las plantas para
conseguir respuestas y medicinas
para nuestras enfermedades y qué pasa si
las perdemos entonces mi trabajo es
básicamente mi cámara salir al
campo
por una serie de eventos fortuitos que
hay en el tema pero ya tengo la
responsabilidad de tratar de identificar
todas las que pueda no solamente aquí
sino que próximamente
voy a estar trabajando también en cuba y
en jamaica eventualmente para tratar de
describir todo lo que están en el
pendiente de descripción en el caribe o
sea que nada esperemos que eso eso sirva
a alguien que sí vaya a hacer un trabajo
para agregar valor directo a nosotros
pero por lo pronto
estoy gozando con eso gracias